is each piece equal to one-fourth of the
area of the pie so we have a pie and it
has 1 2 3 4 pieces so it does have four
pieces so is one of those pieces equal
to 1/4 of the pie well let's talk about
what we mean when we have a fraction
like 1/4 the one in the fraction the
numerator represents the number of
pieces so here one piece one piece of
pie and then the 4 when we're talking
about fractions is always talking about
the number of equal size equal sized
pieces so in this case for equal sized
pieces so the question is is each piece
one of four equal sized pieces let's
look at the pie I think it's pretty
clear that these pieces on the end are
not equal they are smaller than the two
pieces in the middle if you love cherry
pie you are not happy about getting this
end piece because it is smaller it is
not an equal sized piece so yes each
piece is 1 out of 4 pieces but it is not
one of 4 equal sized pieces therefore it
is not 1/4 so our answer is no no no no
each piece is not 1/4 or an equal share
of the pie